alvin kamara has a deal to play one more
year with new orleans saints before he'd
be eligible for the franchise tag or
whatever else may happen
they're trying to get something worked
out in new orleans
my understanding is they're likely to
get it done
by monday but given the way things blew
up earlier this week who the hell knows
camaro was back at practice on wednesday
an encouraging sign given that there was
a perception like joe mixon last week
with his migraines or
air quotes migraines was holding in
camara doing the same with a knee or
whatever it is that was giving him
trouble
he's back and after practice sean payton
the coach
of the new orleans saints addressed the
fact that they are indeed working on a
new contract for alvin kamara here's
peyton
we're actively negotiating a contract
with he and his agent
and uh we'll keep you posted if there's
any progress
if you guys don't reach a contract
agreement do you see this
being something where maybe he doesn't
play week one
i think that's a little uh previous
right now we're focused on
him being a part of our plan week one
we didn't completely close the door i
think he meant to say premature
yes instead of previously but i think i
think you know
they didn't close the door there on him
not playing week one
which is which is kind of jarring and
and which
it it it's another piece of this puzzle
that points to
players having a new type of power chris
getting closer and closer
to what you suggested earlier this week
when we were talking about riley reef
getting squeezed by the vikings to take
less money he eventually did
a player saying i'm just not playing
whether it's an injury that i
actually have that i don't want to put
at risk or it's an injury i don't have
or i just don't
even need to hide behind an injury i'm
not playing until you take care of me
i think it's kind of surprising that
peyton left the door open on the
possibility
of camaro not playing week one yeah i'm
with you i think
players are just continuing to get more
and more business savvy
and trying to figure out real lives
capitalize
on the power they might have within a
football team to get more money and yeah
alvin kamara like we've talked about the
last few days he's got some power there
because he's such a
he's a good player and he's such an
integral part of this making the scheme
work with sean payton
but yeah i mean to me first off
i'd have a hard time thinking that you
know the saints first they say they'd
want a first rounder for alvin kamara i
don't think they're gonna get that at
this point
i don't you know so yeah if they don't
get a deal done here
within the next you know week or so i'm
guessing
the the possibility of alvin kamara not
playing week one is probably a real
possibility
but i have a hard time thinking that
won't happen you know
mike like he kind of falls in that
category a little bit what you talked
about yesterday
you know he was drafted by the team he's
got great fantasy
success so he's homegrown everybody's
seen him the team
wins when he's been there and everybody
looks at it and i feel like the you know
the saints have
put themselves into a corner here where
yeah they're gonna have to pay the guy
and and probably
bend and maybe pay a little bit more
than they really want to here
yeah i mean the point being that this is
the first guy
who's in position to get paid like a
high-end workhorse running back
who isn't used right like a high-end
workhorse running back
i think the difference in touches last
year for
alvin kamara and christian mccaffrey
who's getting 16 million a year
mccaffrey was north of 400.
camaro was in the range of i think
220 to 250 that's a huge difference in
usage
and he's on the brink of falling
somewhere between joe mixon at 12
and christian mccaffrey at 16 million
per year
and isn't it wild i saw this yesterday
exactly 81 receptions
each of the three years of his career
what a strange coincidence
on 81 three straight seasons but look at
the yards
per reception how it's gone from ten two
to eight eight to six
six isn't that strange to see that kind
of a drop yeah it's strange
i think you know one maybe health is a
part of that like last year we know he
so he's not breaking tackles and getting
yards after the catch maybe like he used
to
right so that probably affected it the
other thing is
he's become such a key part of the
offense people i think have just honed
in on them where it's just like
hey where's 41 where's 13. okay there's
michael thomas there's alvin kamara
we got special calls and special things
we're gonna do
to take them out of the pass game or at
least limit the damage they're gonna do
and i i would think that more or less is
the biggest reason for why it's dropped
and of course the injuries like he told
us at the super bowl this year they were
real
and he played through them yeah he
played through them and he still had a
solid season but
but not the season that we're accustomed
to but again
the saints privately believe that alvin
kamara is every bit as good as christian
mccarthy and i've been told multiple
times now
once the panthers paid mccaffrey 16
million that is when the saints
soiled their pants yeah frankly i don't
know that that will get the message at
the bottom of the screen in the uk but
sorry
that's when they got very concerned
about the future
and about what alvin camaro was going to
want because if they believe he's as
good as mccaffrey
and mccaffrey's getting 16. where does
camara come in
when you don't use him the way the
panthers use i think that christian
mccabe that's the big thing mike that's
the big thing the usage and
you know a little bit of just the whole
offense is based around christian
mccaffrey
and carolina and you were right with
your numbers
you know alvin kamara was around 250
touches last year
you know yes mccaffrey was above 400
so that just tells you in itself you
know every game
every play decoy-wise mccaffrey is a
huge part of all that
camaro is a part of that in new orleans
to a degree
yes but they have other weapons and of
course they have one of the greatest
offensive game plan designers in the
history of the football
who's gotten just about every running
back that's played for him off in the
passing game
so let's not forget that i mean
whoever's gone there to play running
back
gets catches in the pass game so uh i
think yeah
and i think they probably have told
alvin kamara how great he is camaro how
great he is and
that's also you know it's
they've they're stuck where yeah they're
going to have to pay him but i don't
think they're getting close to christian
mccaffery number i don't think that's
happening
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights from nbc sports